Clustering or Cluster Analysis is one of the
foundational and most important tasks that you
can do in unsupervised machine learning. The
general idea is to take an entire collection
of cases or observations and put them together.
Now the important thing to remember is these are
not natural groupings, rather these are Groups
of Convenience. They're not the platonic real
universals that cut nature on its joints. They're
groups of cases that are similar to each other,
but with a pragmatic goal. You group the
cases to accomplish a specific purpose.
And the real merit of the grouping is how well
does it serve that purpose. You can think of this
as a version of Functionalism. And the question
is, which cases can be treated in the same way
depending on a specific purpose?
Clustering serves really important
purposes in a lot of different fields.
To give you a few examples, in Marketing the idea
here is that you make offers to people who are in
similar categories. You give them the same kind
of ads. You recommend the same products to them.
It's extremely common in Marketing. In Medicine,
you would use clustering to identify similar
patients or cases or outbreaks or even medications
that can be used for similar kinds of diseases and
disorders. In Ecology and Zoology, you can use it
to identify species and ways of categorizing the
environments that they live in.
Although it's not formally used in Law, the basic
idea here is you're trying to argue that one case
is similar to another. If you wanted to do a
quantitative analysis, you could establish that,
for this particular purpose, this case, is
in the same category as all of these others
and they go together and they're different from
these ones. That's what Cluster Analysis is about.
Note that clusters are pragmatic groupings. They
really serve a particular purpose for the analyst
or the purpose using them. What clusters do is
they allow limited interchangeability between
the objects within the cluster. You want to hear
these songs together. You’re going to give the
same ads to this group over here. These people get
the same medical treatment. And the approach is in
the validity of clustering varies according to
the individual person's purpose, the data that's
fed into the system and the algorithm used.
The algorithm defines what it means to be
similar and it also defines how to measure
distance and what it means to be a cluster.
There are many choices available. They
fall into a few general categories.
For instance, there are methods that measure the
distance between points like euclidean distance.
There are others that measure distance from
a centroid, others that look at the density
of the data in the space and others that use
distributional models. If you have graph data,
that is network data, there are other models too.
Let's start by taking a quick look at distance
algorithms. Imagine you have a collection
of points here in two dimensional space
and that's one cluster in orange and you've
got another cluster here in blue. What you're
going to do is you're going to measure the
distance from every point to every other point.
Think of it as measuring the direct distance
between each of them and these are also known
as connectivity models. One of the neat things
you get from these is a hierarchical diagram.
One of the interesting choices here is whether you
want to do a joining or splitting approach. Those
are actually technically known as agglomerative
or divisive. You either start with all of the
data in one cluster and then take it apart or
you start with all observations separately and
then join them together sequentially. One of the
tricks here is that, these distance models really
only find convex clusters. That is if you're in
a two dimensional or three dimensional shape.
The other major limitation is that while
the distance models are easy to describe,
they're really slow for big data because you
have to compute a big number of distances.
The next most common methods are the centroid
based models. Imagine that you have cluster of
points here and what we get with this diamond is
a point that defines the mean in multi-dimensional
space here. What it does then is it looks at
the distance from every point in a group to that
centroid. The center point here, the centroid,
is defined by a mean vector, so it's the mean
for that group on every variable that you have in
the dimensional space. The most common version of
this is what's called k-means and that's where you
simply define how many centroids you want to have
and then it figures out how far each
point is from so many different centroids.
Like the distance models, the centroid model finds
convex clusters but with an extra limitation.
They're generally of similar size. The other major
problem is you have to choose the value for k,
the number of clusters that you want
to have. There are some interesting
adaptation sways around that but generally,
you just kind of pick a number and you give
that to the computer and see how well it works.
Next, there are density algorithms and this is
where you look in the multi-dimensional space and
it simply computes the density of points in there
and it draws a border around them so for instance.
What you're doing here is you're connecting dense
regions in k-dimensional space where k is the
number of variables or attributes that you have.
What's neat about this is, these
approaches can model non-convex clusters.
You see for instance how the orange one bends in.
It can also model clusters of different sizes.
The blue one's smaller, the orange one's bigger
and so it overcomes some of the limitations of
other approaches. One interesting thing is,
it is possible to sort of ignore outliers
or unusual cases because they're not in
dense regions. The major problem however
is that it's hard to describe exactly how
the algorithm arrived at these things.
You don't have a parametric distribution to say
that this cluster's defined by high scores on
this variable and low scores on that one because
it might be an unusual shape that wraps around.
The fourth collection of algorithms are
distributions or distributional models.
Imagine we have our points here and we draw a sort
of normal shape around them in a bivariate model
that's going to look like an ellipse. Here we draw
an approximate ellipse around these points so what
we're doing here is we're getting the clusters and
we're modeling them as statistical distributions.
Now, you have a lot of choices but by far
the most common is a multivariate normal
distribution and we’re showing that
with the variate loose ellipses here.
There's one major problem to the distributional
approach is that, it is prone to overfit. That is,
if you give the computer free rein, it'll just
add more and more dimensions until you end up with
models that really only apply to the exact data
that you currently have. Now, you can overcome
that by telling it how many dimensions to work
with, similar to the k-means, and tell it how
many clusters. One advantage though is, it's good
at capturing the correlations or interrelations
between the attributes in your data, which none of
the other approaches do specifically. On the other
hand, it also is limited to convex clusters,
because that's the shape of our distributions.
In summary, there are multiple definitions of
clusters. There's definitions of what it means
to be a cluster, how do they define distance
and how to define shape. While there are
several categories of algorithms, each of them has
different strengths and limitations. For instance,
some only do convex shapes, some do equal size
clusters, some are difficult for large data sets,
some are hard to describe parametrically. So,
when it comes down to actually conducting your
cluster analysis, you need to be mindful of
these options and try to choose an algorithm
that both fits your data and fits the purposes
or pragmatic applications of your analysis.